في الباحه الاماميه للبرلمان الاوروبي في
ستراسبور تجمع ايرانيون من مدن اوروبيه
مختلفه يجمعهم مطلب واحد فهدف المتظاهرين
الاولي مطالبه المجتمع الدولي بوضع لحارسه
ثوري على قائمه الارهاب منجدين طبعا
بنتهاكات النظام الايراني والاعدامات
المتواصله شخصيات شهيره عده معارضه للنظام
الايراني عبرت عن دعمها للتجمع كناجل شاه
ايران السابق رضا بهلوي وعلي كريمي وغيرها
هؤلاء اهالي ضحايا الطائره الاوكرانيه
ايضا المتظاهرات والمظاهرات التي جرت
والتي تحمل نفس المطلب المتكرر منذ ثلاث
سنوات هذا واكد سياسيون بينهم عضو
بالبرلمان البريطاني ضروره قرار الحارس
الثوري منظمه ارهابيه وقطع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه البريطانيه مع ايران على
خلفيه طبعا اعدام المواطن البريطانيه علي
رضا اكبر وكا متاسفارتان الالمانيه
والفرنسيه في ايران نشرتها صورا جديده
لسفيرهما مع السفير البريطاني فيما وصف
انه تضامن اوروبي في قضيه اغتيال اكبر غير
ان هذه الصور طالتها انتقادات من ناشطين
دعوا هذه الدول لسحب السفراء وقطع
العلاقات وليست تصوير فقط
ضخمه بالتحديد هنا امام مقر البرلمان
الاوروبي وذلك للمطالبه بادراج الحرس
الثوري الايراني على لائحه المنظمات
الارهابيه للاتحاد الاوروبي ويشارك في هذا
التحرك متظاهرون من حوالي 50 مدينه
اوروبيه توقيت هذه التظاهره ايضا يتزامى
مع اجتماعا للبرلمان الاوروبي للبحث في
سبل فرد عقوبات جديده على ايران بعد
الاعدامات الاخيره وسيحضره ايضا مفوض
السياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
المتظاهرون اطلقوا هتافات مؤيده
للاحتجاجات في ايران
ضد الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران وكذلك
حملوا رسائل موجهه الى البرلمانيين
الاوروبيين كتب عليها كونوا صوتنا وماذا
تنتظرون بعد لاضافه الحارس السوري
الايراني على لائحه المنظمات الارهابيه
هذه التظاهره لن تكون الاخيره لكن
المتظاهرين هنا يعولون على ايتها والضغط
الذي تشكله على القاده الاوروبيين لمنع
نصب المزيد من المشانق في ايران فذي دهوك
العربيه ستراسبورغ